[Music]
all right so I gotta ask this now it's
it's great you you're astrophysicist and
theoretical physicist and by the way for
you kids
listening this is this is how you get a
free education always be the dumbest
person in the car but I know Neil if I'm
not mistaken Newton is your favorite
science team I'm an okay justjust don't
don't don't even get me started okay so
I'm interested because you being a
theoretical physicist I have I won't
assume but I have a good idea who your
guy might be you me besides Neil I got a
feeling it's got to be Einstein it's
Einstein
I love his thought experiment about time
because they're so naive in a way in a
way what he accomplished and those
thought experiments was how to be naive
in other words how to not be too
complicated and too sophisticated so
when we think about the nature of time
we get confused by all these
distractions is it because we know too
much and you got to subtract a few
layers of knowledge yes we have so much
experience we have too much experience
of the world and so we have to unlearn
some things because our experience of
the world fools us into believing things
that aren't true so if I look at two
astronauts floating in space or
something exactly the minute that they
cross paths but you can see them as
you're crossing paths they're gonna
argue about which one of them is moving
right and you're not gonna be able to
solve that question because there's
nothing relative
to which they can measure their motion
accept each other and so there's no way
to resolve the argument but he wasn't
thinking about astronauts he was
thinking about train which didn't exist
yet which didn't exist yet he's thinking
about trains and it's much but the train
seems to be moving relative to the
Earth's you get confused when we've been
on train cars where we're like on Amtrak
let's say there's another one right next
to you and one starts moving and you
think it's you but it's that and so
that's in that instant yeah the the
relativity of motion is completely
manifest yeah but it it was like he was
able to remove all the confusion say in
some sense forget about the platform and
the earth just stick of the Train just
into the train just think of the Train
and and and becoming more and more naive
and singularly focused you have this
beautiful revelation and it's so
beautiful
it is and and to be able to use trains
because it's something that we everyone
knows yeah it was probably not guessed
the most advanced form of Transportation
and his yeah of course you have to
wonder how much it influenced his own
thinking to just having that form of
transportation and it still works today
yes actually I know a great place to go
discuss the thought experiments with the
chains